thanks for passing me in my candidacy
defense or my defense 35 years ago so it
was 35 years ago this week that I left
actually Stanford for uh Caltech many of
you didn't have the great opportunity
that I did to get advice from Bernie
rothering her PhD so I will pass on one
that he told me right before I went out
for my first job talk he said Joel
on your best day ever ten percent of
your audience will sleep just get over
it
um and so Bernie you can lead the chorus
of snorers right now
um so besides uh having spent uh 40
years in robotics I also work on
biomedical devices but today I want to
use actually a kind of cheesy
over-the-top biomimetic inspiration so I
sort of started working in my first
robots over 40 years ago and we don't
actually have robots that can do this
today whereby you can swoop down you
actually as you'll see later have to
carefully control the Feathering of your
wings near the ground because of a
ground effect you have to actually
iterate it and generate a lot of forces
to control the grasping of that fish and
I'm even more ambitious I'd like to be
able to do something like this while
there's a big wind and then maybe the
person who owns that fish pond is not
real happy and throws a shoe at this
bird as well for poaching that fish so I
don't know how to solve all these
problems yet but we're working on pieces
that we'd like to sort of put together
and so I'm going to tell you about some
of the pieces today that hopefully would
get to this sort of future of high
performance in Dynamic tasks
so using kind of the biological uh idea
for a minute um this is our two model
organisms that I've been evolving in my
lab the first one is called squid it's a
streamlined quick unfolding
investigative drone and the Practical
motivation is this this work was funded
by the military and so what they'd like
to have is if military are out in parole
on patrol and they want to be able to
kind of quick get an eye in the sky to
see what's happening for me I'm actually
quite inspired by the unfortunately
unpleasant fact that we have lots of
fires in California and plenty of
firefighters oftentimes get trapped in
flames and so it'd be good if they could
also quickly get something into the sky
very quickly to sort of get surveillance
of what's happening in the nearby
environment
so to launch a drone today you typically
have to put it on the ground and then
sort of manually sort of help the
launching process drilling sometimes are
failure proof or failure prone once they
sort of take off
also they can't actually be shut off a
moving vehicle and moreover they take
time to kind of unfold and kind of
deploy so we spent a couple of years
working on a couple of generations of
these squid devices which can then
ballistically be launched
and so um our first squid as you see
here looks like a World War II V2 rocket
because that's the most streamlined
design uh possible it's the same
diameter as a baseball because this is a
baseball pitching machine that launches
it and the sort of Simple Theory in this
first version I'm talking about Dynamic
tasks and stability is actually if you
design this thing so that at every
instant the center of gravity is above
the center of pressure during the arm
unfolding process it will be sort of
passively stable
so this is actually out in the desert
about two hours north of Caltech we
actually were shooting these things off
a truck at 50 miles an hour and so
here's sort of showing you the launch
process there's actually a
computer-controlled mechanism that
releases the arms at a predetermined
height in this early version there's
actually you can't see it there's a
actually a world-class pilot on the side
of the road who then sort of Takes Over
Control
um it helps sort of stabilize it
so here you'll see the bird's eye view
of the launch process
and so after a little bit of turkey and
Tweety The Simple Theory of a passive
aerodynamic stability actually worked
100 of the time quite reliably so the
next thing we started looking at is can
we actually autonomously stabilize these
vehicles and so this is a larger we call
it squid 2 or as my students call it the
Kraken because it actually weighs three
kilograms uh it can really hurt you at
70 miles an hour if you're not careful
and so this one actually has onboard
autonomy so there's onboard lidars and
cameras and Computing and things we also
because we wanted to launch it at higher
speeds and also we found out from our
first one that these drones experience
forces over 100 G's during the launch
process so you can imagine if you're
shot out of a cannon at 100 G's all your
sensors are going to be uh kind of
completely fluid and so we have to sort
of make this careful balance between
passive stability when we launch and
then sort of transition over to active
stability and sort of figure out which
sensors uh can actually be deployed at
which time
and also uh how to sort of stabilize
this so we developed a kind of a scaling
Theory which would allow us then to use
an open air wind tunnel out Caltech that
you'll see prominently several times
today uh be used so we could launch
little two-inch prototypes and if we
could stabilize these sort of little
two-inch prototypes in the wind flow
which is coming this way along to
different angles of the theory would
tell us that we would actually be
passively stable up to about 80 miles an
hour of sort of launch speed
so um here's um
this is in the center for autonomous
systems and Technologies at Caltech is
basically a drone Arena and a robot
arena in this particular version we
actually released the propellers and
release these fins so these large fins
actually poke out of the weight stream
so that it sort of passively stabilizes
itself in a large range of sort of
conditions and so what you'll see then
is there's a sequence of sensors turning
on after they're sort of you know
blacked out from the 100g force of
launching and then we primarily then the
only sensor that really works throughout
the launch process is sort of computer
vision so we use completed Vision to
stabilize these things until they reach
a sufficient height and actually then
reach sufficient stability or quietness
of the sensors so they can take over and
act like a regular drone now the problem
is this thing will work 100 of the time
in a fairly steady win but if you have a
really complex wind like in the case of
the firefighters we're not sure whether
this thing will be stable
but um this stability was enough that
we've actually convinced the JPL the jet
propulsion laboratory to change how the
future missions to Mars will be done uh
by helicopters so many of you familiar
with the current Mars helicopter which
has been a great success it can only
carry about a 50 Grand payload but
because of our work we're now involved
in two projects that I'll tell you about
today with JPL to look at future drones
from ours the first one is to use small
ones like the one that you saw here
which could be then launched out of an
AeroShell in a larger mission to
actually drop multiple investigators
over the planet the real one we're
looking at right now is the max Mars
helicopter if it's funded by Congress
we'd be about 13 feet in diameter and a
hexacopter and carry about a three to
five kilogram payload and because of the
work that we've done we've shown that
we're able to actually launch this in
midair so instead of Landing It On The
Ground it'll actually be deployed about
five kilometers above the surface and
then sort of flood her down which will
allow us to get to new science areas
that we can't get to right now and
drastically reduce the cost of the
mission now the other problem that we're
faced with in the future of Mars
helicopter mission is the ability to do
science that's actually what drives all
these missions uh in NASA and Congress
and so um what the current Rovers on
Mars have found is that some of the most
interesting geological and scientific
sort of treasures are actually on the
sides of very very steep slopes and so
the question is how do we get there and
so with the limited payload that we have
from the current even future designs
it's almost impossible to get there so
the current idea is instead of sending
Rovers or astronauts there is to
actually use a helicopter but in the
following way so you would drop the
helicopter in the atmosphere and then
drop a payload of a bunch of different
sensor modules uh down on the ground the
helicopter would then actually go find
the sensor modules go do some
reconnaissance and figure out where it
would be an interesting spot to place
these modules then actually pick up
these modules and then sort of go have
them grip onto the walls and the
technology you use as you'll see in a
second is the micro spine grippers that
actually came out of Market costumes lab
so um one of the things you can imagine
and this is sort of where we've been
pushing the envelope is that actually
these sensor modules will be very heavy
especially compared to the weight of the
Drone so those of you familiar with
aerial manipulation know that trying to
manipulate a very heavy payload on a
drone is a tough problem because as
you're Shifting the center of mass
around it can become quite unstable
requires huge huge lifting forces that
are impossible to get from conventional
drones so we have two innovations one of
which I'll talk about today and one
maybe in a future talk one Innovation is
a practical design so this is a payload
shifting arm that actually deposits sort
of the sensors so actually the batteries
and CPU are actually back here so as
this sort of extends out we actually
maintain the center of Mass to within
about two or three centimeters of the
sort of native one and so
the idea then is that this arm has a
special uh end effector here which can
then deposit these payloads these
payloads have marks micro spine gripper
on them then batteries computers and up
to 500 grams of sensors so the whole
thing weighs about a kilogram and a half
uh and this drone's only three and a
half kilograms so we're talking about 40
of the payload of the Drone the other
Innovation is some new work on
differential flatness and non-linear
control using differential flatness but
we don't really need it here and so
these micro spine grippers because of
Mark's brilliant work in Aaron Parnes
can actually hold these centers up for
over a month at a time and then we've
built the interface here so not only can
we deposit them but we can actually
retract them and then go replace them as
we go forward
so here's the basic idea and why it's
closer to that sort of biomimetic idea
that I showed before we can't just touch
and go like most people do in aerial
manipulation we actually have to do a
lot of manipulation with the environment
to get these things to be stable so the
idea is we use an onboard camera to sort
of take a Target identified by a human
operator insert a Servo on that then we
actually contact the wall and press into
the wall so we get sufficient forces and
then the micro spine gripper coordinates
with the computer to kind of close and
grip then actually the Drone using a
force sensor pulls on the sensor and to
test that it's okay and then it kind of
releases so let's see all that in action
again this is in our drone facility at
Caltech
so this is manual at this point now it's
switching over to autonomous this tether
is not necessary it's just for a
requirement for safety uh so now you're
seeing it extending out the arm again
you're seeing it keeps the sort of
stable balance relatively easy because
of the mass shifting capability uh at
the end of the arm is the payload there
that thin thing is the sensor that's
actually a basalt rock
um actually that's very similar to a
native Basalt on Mars
there you can see the close-up and then
over on the side there you can see
actually all the data in terms of either
position or later actually in terms of
forces and so now it's pushing it's
coordinating with a micro spine gripper
it pulled on it and then it sort of
found that it could detach
so this is great we're very happy with
this but we're now interested not only
on Mars but actually doing this in the
real world
and so how can we take things like the
Kraken that I showed you before and work
them in very complex flows like in a
fire or take this and work in the
outside world where you may have things
like when these vehicles get close to a
wall uh there's a sort of interactive
fluid structure interactions that
actually cause complex forces to be
applied to the drones
uh and it's particularly excited if
you're working in close proximity you
know in some kind of building or other
kinds of things the flows there are very
complex and make the control very
difficult the other thing is out in the
real world
um we're also going to have lots of sort
of you know wins and biases Etc so um
how can we adapt to these effects so I'm
going to sort of talk about two
techniques today
um so the first one for those of you who
read my abstract is based on the idea of
a coupon operator but before I get into
the ideas of that let me just quick give
you a survey of actually how pretty much
all learning for flight control and
actually even General robotic vehicle
control goes
and so the idea is assume that you have
some dynamical system we can describe
it's governing mechanics by some
equation x dot equals F of the Dynamics
of X the state U the control and W is
some disturbance or unknown force or
unmodel Dynamics
um so you can either say hey I've got a
nominal control system so like in drones
we can just use the onboard usual
controller when you're actually out not
near buildings or in complex flows and
that works pretty well but when you're
in a complex environment then what you
may want to do is learn sort of this
disturbance as we call it or residual as
we call it so this is called residual
learning the other and I'm going to talk
about that second the other approach is
you can actually try to learn the
Dynamics directly and for particular
reasons because if you can learn the
Dynamics directly then you can apply
actually control techniques where you
can get things like guaranteed stability
guaranteed safety
and also start to you know answer
questions about how much data do I need
to learn
Etc
so what we'd like to do is not only be
safe during deployment but actually be
safe and rigorous and stable and
provable during the learning process as
well
so I know these techniques are not yet
popular at Stanford although I know
Marco Pavone's group is working with
George holler on things that are related
to it but if you've never seen koopin
techniques before the idea is very
straightforward so if I start with an
autonomous dynamical system
x dot equals f of x I'm ignoring the
control right now normally what you do
is you sort of study the flows of that
dynamical system which may be non-linear
and you study kind of the geometry of
the phase space and so all the theory is
based on how these geometry sort of uh
you know uh evolves over time to study
stability or robustness or convergence
Etc
back in 1932 uh coopman came up with
this idea which was basically lost to
time until around 2000 when it was kind
of rediscovered by a person who's doing
this PhD at Caltech is ew or mesic and
what coupon sort of said is instead of
looking at the state space let me Define
a space of observables so an observable
thing like momentum energy could be the
actual coordinates of the state system
as well but that space now is a function
space instead of a finite dimensional
State space and what coupon showed is
that actually there's an equivalent
linear but infinite dimensional system
which actually mimics the Dynamics of
this finite dimensional law in the year
system and so in theory then if you're
willing to pay the price to lift this to
very very high Dimensions you can then
use sort of linear control theory on
this potentially there's a problem we'll
see in a second now in practice no one
wants to work with the infinite
dimensional system in the real
engineering system so what people do
then is lift this up to let's say you
have a three degree physic system here
you might lift this to 14 dimensions 15
dimensions and make a finite
approximation to this infinite
dimensional lifting but the thing that
you know is if you're willing to pay
that price is you get a truly sort of
linear system it's guaranteed to be
linear now the finite dimensional
approximation there's some issues and
there's still ongoing work to understand
the effects of those approximations
so now when we add control inputs it's
not quite as pleasant and what you find
is that actually
um when you tried to do that lifting
process the sort of autonomous part goes
fine that actually does lift to uh
actually linear part but the control
part doesn't it lifts to the sort of
very complicated equation right here but
under certain conditions which are
satisfied for almost all relevant
engineering and robotic systems what you
can show is all this term here collapses
down and by change of coordinates can be
made a simple product of a consonant
Matrix G times a vector Z which is the
lifted sort of variables so it's a
bilinear system so it's not quite linear
but it's sort of bilinear
um and so uh there's a rapidly growing
uh actually research field in this area
and so what our group has been working
on is how do we actually learn the sort
of bidil in your systems uh directly
from data that's the Brilliance of the
Koop and idea is that because you're
working in the space of observables you
don't have to measure the state what you
do is you measure actually how the
system looks to you in the real world
and that gives you the indirect
information about what's happening in
the state space
so now the problem is of course is both
how do we do this from data and the
other thing is the original theory that
developed these set of techniques
assumed that actually all the control
inputs that you use to ID the system
were open loop which is a disaster for
robotics of course you can't just run
your robot around let it crash
everywhere so um we've developed a
member of techniques and the reason we
like the coupon thing is because then
you can use the favorite tool that robot
Engineers love to use which is model
predictive control so this is an optimal
control technique so you have some cost
function so now the cost function is
going to be in the control inputs like
regular model prediction control and
it's now going to be in the lifted
States so you use regular linear NPC
like ideas
again the key advantage of using these
coupon techniques is if you can learn
this model then you can actually do
control with constraints and
reinforcement learning you can't
actually learn and actually have
constraints taken into account so this
learning method any kind of constraint
that you can imagine we can build into
the calculation process and then effect
into the learning process so we can
learn with constraints execute with
constraints and you know that's what
real Engineers you know love to do
so now because it's a bilinear system
and not truly linear we have to do an
approximation in the NPC so I talking
with lunch today with most people it
seems like you guys are familiar with
sequential quadratic programming and so
we use a sequential quadratic
programming technique to do that so um
because I wanted this to be more of an
overview talk today and not too
technical
um you'll see a bunch of list of papers
here if you want to go through a fine
further details so I'm just going to
gloss through this one quickly those of
you who are familiar with fluid
mechanics and know something about a DMD
Dynamic mode decomposition we've sort of
figured out the equivalent of dynamic
mode decomposition for these sort of
robot control problems and so the idea
is you fly your drone around or you
drive your vehicle around and you sort
of gather a bunch of data you go through
a bunch of calculations and now it pops
a bilinear approximation of a particular
Dimension that you have to actually
specify ahead of time so that's still an
open question I'm not going through many
details there because it seems like most
of the world these days is interested in
deep Nets and so just recently last year
one of my students figured out actually
how to put all of this in a deep neural
network you can go see the details but
I'm going to give you the concept right
now so in order to do this coupon
Learning what we want to figure out is
how do we lift so we need this lifting
function which is called a coupe and
eigenfunction so you need to learn the
eigen function
all right so we use that auto encoder to
basically minimize the error between the
projection of the lifted function and
the actual State data that we get
then you have a part which actually
looks at how good is the predictive
capability of this lifted model right
you wanted to be able to mimic the
system and then finally we have a part
which actually learns the sort of
bilinearization of the system and so you
can then have a deep neural network
which actually has three terms it's make
a good lifting
all right make it predict well
and make sure you learn sort of the
dynamic f and g matrices properly
okay so let's see this in action
so here's a little crazy fly maybe those
of you know these are five or six inch
diameter drones and so this is again in
our flight Arena at Caltech so on the
top is after three minutes of training
this is what actually our coupon model
can do on the bottom is sort of a
state-of-the-art non-linear model
predictive control so when we're having
them actually fly at 25 centimeters or
10 inches above the ground the ground
effect is there but it's not very large
so both of these things look equivalent
but actually if you look carefully at
the data what you find out is
the coupon model actually learns the
ground effect very well so it's actually
able to keep the desired 25 centimeter
height
the ground effect actually adds extra
buoyancy to the Drone and so what
happens is it sort of flies the right
trajectory but it's way too high because
it doesn't understand these buoyant
forces and also doesn't understand how
the buoyant forces vary with height
all right so now let's actually try to
have these drones fly below the level
where actually the ground effect is very
important so this is less than the
diameter of the Drone and so what you'll
see in the bottom is the nonlinear model
predictive control actually crashes
repeatedly it actually can't fly we can
actually get these drones down to one
inch above the surface you know at full
speed and actually sort of control them
without crashing or stable or being
unstable
so there's a little bit about learning
the second part of my talk was about
risk and I'm going to couple the two at
the end of each other and so uh you know
this is a huge problem in robotics so
I'm not the first person to study this
there's much active work here at
Stanford which is why I want to talk
about this today in fact uh Professor
Pavone wrote a lovely lovely paper on
the role of risk in robotics
and so in general not even necessarily
thinking about risk what you'd like to
know is if robots are now going to
operate in human-like environments where
there's kids playing ball and dogs
running around and cars that are driving
uh you know how should they model the
world how should they sort of plan their
emotions to account for all the
uncertainty and we're also dealing with
learn systems so actually how should
they account for the fact that they
actually don't fully understand their
learned models as well
and so classically as at lunch today I
heard some of you are working on
stochastic motion planning that's great
so you know these kinds of problems can
be formulated in the following way I
want to plan a trajectory and it deals
with uncertain system so I have an
uncertain model of the world
um you know choose your favorite
distribution we'll talk about that later
and so I'll take some cost function
which may be non-linear and I'll try to
minimize that cost function even with
the unmodeled or partially modeled
disturbances and then potentially with
some kind of constraints that deal with
the fact that I don't want to bump into
kids or crash my drone or crash into
another car
so the major approaches up until a
couple of years ago were either again
planning an expectation so you figure
out what's the expected value of the
problems that you're going to face all
right and also make what's called a
chance constraint to make sure that your
constraints of not bumping into things
are probabilistic so you want to make
sure there's a minimum probability that
I don't Clash or crash into something
using sort of some Physics model of how
I would crash or how I would bump into
people
um or you could use Minimax or worst
case kind of planning which is
um I'll minimize the maximum worst case
of this function again using constraints
but we don't have to use those two
extremes there's actually Extremes in
the middle
and so particularly if we have some kind
of distribution of uncertainty here in
this sort of one-dimensional cartoon
planning and expectation is planning
sort of for the mean
planning in worst case is planning at
the very sort of worst possible
disturbance so that you basically take
care of all of these disturbances up
here but you get very very conservative
and rather sluggish kinds of results
the mean is good you'll typically get
nice sort of you know proactive kind of
planners but you ignore the Tails and
you still get collisions because of the
tails
so the risk-based view of this is to
sort of say Hey you know there's other
parts of the distribution that we may be
concerned with are different ways to
actually calculate the cost of dealing
with these uncertain distributions in
our world and so that's where risk aware
planning comes in is actually using the
different calculi on sort of the
possible uncertainties
and so um we can also then
formulate our
chance constraints in here so normally
with a Chance constraint we have the
goal that actually the probability that
will violate our chance constraint
exceeds some kind of threshold
and in the case of the chance constraint
what we can do is instead of actually
thinking about the probability in terms
of mean or worst case we can actually
kind of titrate somewhere in the middle
and again use different sort of ways to
measure the uncertainty as we'll talk
about in a moment
and more importantly everyone knows in
robotics that you don't want to assume a
gaussian or some other distribution you
don't know the distribution at all and
so what you'd really like to be able to
do is to actually handle all kinds of
distribution it's not every possible
distribution but a big range of
distributions that you think will either
be at play or that actually you can
actually come up with numerical
techniques to find the limits of these
distributions sort of during your
learning or execution phase
so in essence learning the expectation
then over these distributions
um will kind of get you close to kind of
the mean kind of problem but again we
can actually now think of actually a
risk-based uh sort of distributionally
robust sort of way of looking at the
world what we're saying is especially
I'll talk about a little bit later
something called cvar which is
conditional value at risk which is
what's it going to cost me on average to
be sort of robust against this tale here
so now in a distributionally robust way
is what's it going to cost me to be
robust against the tale of all possible
distributions in my distribution set
so um in the finance literature starting
about 25 years ago people started
thinking about these ideas they first
came from Finance where there's real
money involved and so there's a class of
risk measures called coherent risk
measures and the ideas are quite simple
so if you have four properties a
translation or variance which means if I
add a consonant which is not uncertain
to my cost then it'll just add a
constant cost to my risk evaluation
if I have more uncertainty I should have
more risk basically a triangle
inequality for a risk and uncertainty
and then a multiplicative effect as well
and if your risk measure actually
satisfies all these four properties then
there's something called the
representation theorem which tells you
the following thing which is the actual
risk measure is equivalent to the
following convex optimization so it's
the optimization Nation over the convex
set of a set of unknown distributions of
whatever your sort of cost function is
and so those of you who worry about
real-time controls know that if we can
always reformulate a problem in terms of
convex properties we can then use convex
optimization to actually get real-time
performance
and so um over there it's just showing
you some of the different types of risk
measures that people have introduced and
actually sort of the geometry of the
convex sets that are equivalent to those
risk measures
okay so let's put this to work
um the first place we worked it used it
was actually just in static environments
so I'm proud to say I'm the only person
on Earth who's actually been in all five
DARPA challenges and so this is the most
recent challenge of the Subterranean
challenge where we had to send teams of
robots into underground tunnels and
caves and structures to actually go find
40 objects that we'd never seen before
so we knew there was a cell phone we
just didn't know what brand cell phone
it was we knew there was a red backpack
but one they would never seen before and
we also actually had to report their
location very accurately or we didn't
get a score we had to do this all in one
hour and there could be no humans in the
course you could only have one human on
the outside talk to your robots if you
built your own communication Network and
brought your own light and brought your
own power
so um
you know these some of these
environments were very very complex and
stream with rubble so we wanted to
actually do some terrain analysis and we
actually found these risk sensitive
ideas to be very very useful for kind of
terrain analysis so using all the
different kinds of sensors we actually
came up with different risks based on
how rugged the terrain was how sloped it
was how much the elevation was How
likely were we to kind of collide with
things you'll see with water and other
kinds of things and so then we just used
a an actual occupancy grid map but we
actually then evaluated each cell by
this conditional value at risk so what's
the cost of the tail of the uncertainty
and then we actually combined all of
these
different metrics together into one risk
cost and then use the risk to actually
plan the motion of the robot
so this is in if you've been up to
Northern California to Lava Tubes
National Park this is in lava tubes
National Park this is a spot from Boston
Dynamics these things are fantastic but
they're dumb as a brick and so you put
all your own autonomy on it and so there
you see this robot is exploring this
part of the cave and so what you see is
the risk map there it's sort of saying
hey how risky is it for me to kind of
wander around you may say like why did
it I'll play it again why did it
actually uh go in this little corner
here because it was actually trying to
cover this area and so this little
corner that you'll see in a second
um it's like hey I haven't really seen
back there so I need to go back there
and see if there's a body back there or
something that's going to kind of give
me a point all right but then it sort of
figures out the risk of sort of going
back there
um and so
here's something that would be difficult
to do for a regular occupancy grid
planner so this is in a limestone cave
actually in Kentucky and so this is
during a simulated sort of final contest
it was two weeks before the final
contest and so the robot was trying to
get up way up high there and it actually
had to find a route through
this little operator voice so it
actually had to find a route through all
of that Rubble there and so it used
these risk-based maps to do it and the
other thing we can do with risk is we
had an hour to complete these things so
we actually dialed up the risk as the
time got late so the robots would do
riskier and riskier things so this robot
actually fell down about three minutes
after this video because it was in the
extreme risk mode it was just willing to
do anything to try to score
okay here's one of the intermediate
finals we actually had to uh totally
scour a three-floor nuclear reactor core
up in Washington state so this is about
50 meters on a side uh and a couple of
grounds uh floors underground this
nuclear reactor was built but then never
commissioned because it went bankrupt so
there was no actually radioactive
activity in there and so let me just
show you a couple of minutes
so we actually had five robots out on
the course in this particular video so
the way the competition works is once
your robots pass that door they're on
their own they have an hour then to go
find things so
uh not I'm talking about today but there
are things like automatic stair
detectors so it would automatically
figure out their stairs because we
didn't know how many floors there were
it turned out there was three and so we
had to go explore all the possible
floors that could be found there so it's
doing all this autonomously
what you'll see when it gets to the
bottom is because there's no radio
Communication in here each the robots
dropped its own radio node to actually
build a communication Network so as it
gets to the bottom here you're going to
see it's going to squat down and
actually deliver a node which then
allowed it to be the main communication
node for the basement of this nuclear
reactor
so here's the rear camera now we didn't
have this view when we were operating
the only thing we could see is what the
robot saw and remember we had five
robots streaming videos so the operator
is very busy this was video DARPA gave
us later that we could piece together
with our own video
and so it knows about doorways and other
things and so I'm here there's water
darp told us if you see water it could
be up to six feet deep and so water was
a No-No and so what you see is it
actually recognized this as water and
said that's a big risk I don't want to
take and so you see it deviated around
that risk rather than actually walking
through that risk because of this
risk-based terrain analysis
so I won't play the whole video I'll try
to go towards the end here
so this is kind of the map that was put
together in one hour by this team of
five robots walking up and down sort of
multiple stairs
so I said this is about almost 10 000
square meters that actually covered in
one hour and then what you'll see is
actually all the different artifacts
that it found
um you know like a a human dummy and
backpack and cell phone and things like
that
okay all right it's okay to avoid things
that are stationary but what about when
you have moving obstacles how can you
actually use risk actually to handle
moving obstacles
and so we've been studying the following
thing so let's go back to my a person
throwing a shoe at the hawk who's sort
of picking up the fish so now imagine
you have a drone and it's doing some
kind of patrolling motion so it's got a
regular task and then someone's angry at
it or some kid is just not paying
attention and so someone then
potentially you know throws a frisbee or
throws a football or is playing
badminton nearby and let's assume you
have some sensors on board the Drone so
you can particularly pick up these
objects but you may not know anything
about them ahead of time so what you'd
like to find out is can I actually
quickly online
learn the effective dynamics of each
obstacle
and then avoid them as necessary using a
risk-based approach
so um what we decided to do is take a
real Minimus minimalist approach and
that is we assume we couldn't actually
even measure the state of these Dynamics
all we'd actually have available to us
is we could sign find some point on the
obstacle probably the center and we
could track that point
um and we assume we could track it about
as fast as the planner can work and
actually these were actually very noisy
signals so the only thing we had was
just streams of data coming from
tracking this vehicle possibly corrupted
by noise
now in this first work I'm talking about
here we assumed the noise was gaussian
but in recent work that we haven't
published yet it can be actually any
arbitrary distribution
so here's the problem
so someone throws a frisbee at the Drone
while it's patrolling so what you'd like
to be able to do is to actually learn
about the Frisbee Dynamics quickly
enough that I can then take it into
account and then avoid it with high
probability
and so we'll have to make some
assumptions
um and the assumptions are basically
first we can capture its Dynamic with a
certain class of dynamical systems it's
actually a quite large class so that's
not a really restriction and we can
actually find its coordinates on a
regular basis and that actually has some
maximum speed right so if someone shoots
a bullet you're not going to avoid the
bullet it's just too fast so it has to
have some bounded speed we don't know
what that speed is yet
um and so um we actually found an old
idea from the 70s
which turned out to be almost Koopman
um so we're turning this into equipment
Theory but it's not quite there yet so
we take these data streams
um and then we do the following things
so the first is we embed them into
what's called a hanko matrix all of you
have used linear identification Theory
know about angled matrices these are
used in control system identification
then we actually do an eigen
decomposition of these matrices so we
just break them up into eigenvalues
eigenvectors we assume there's noise
there so then what we use is a kind of
the optimal denoising theory that was
actually developed here at Stanford by
David Donahoe
so that we take this hankel Matrix and
we basically split it up into Parts
which are real signal and parts which
are noise now normally people throw the
noise away but we keep the noise and
you'll see why in a second
so then the part that's not noise we
then sort of learn what's the dimension
of the Dynamics of this system from
tokens embedding theorem it gives us an
approximate dimension of the system
and then we sort of basically fit a
dynamical systems to that as we're
evolving with the data in the beginning
the knowledge of the Dynamics is very
poor and the noise is very big all right
and so this particular class dynamical
systems we call are called linear
recurrent relationships it's basically
an auto regressive kind of technique
and what you can do is you can find all
the coefficients for the auto regressive
model directly from the eigenvectors of
the hanklization that you did before
so the brilliant part now is that
actually normally what you would do in
regular sort of theories you would say
let me take the mean trajectory that I
predict but what we do is we take all
the samples of the noise and then we
produce a bootstrap of basically 40 to
50 samples of the noise to sort of say
these are all the trajectories that
actually fit within the sort of noise
spectrum that we've actually learned
with the data so far and so what we want
to do is actually again in a risk aware
way is worry about the Tails of this
distribution of trajectories rather than
the mean of this trajectory
so the next step gets a little wonky and
a little bit fast but uh just listen to
my words rather than worry about the
equations
so the key thing is we want to do a
model predictive control so we assume
that the agent we're controlling our
drone is in this earlier version linear
now it can be arbitrarily non-linear
and what we'd like to do is given kind
of constraints on its motion and cons
and then we want it to avoid all these
obstacles we can avoid multiple
obstacles and the only thing we know
about the obstacles is sort of the data
that we've actually derived so far
online
all right so we use these bootstraps
then to produce sets of possible
distributions of the obstacles
and then we'd like to make sure that we
avoid these sets in some risk-aware way
and so we then assign a risk cost how
much risk are we willing to tolerate uh
from the distribution of these obstacles
that we avoid them
so then the unfortunately the kind of
constraints you have to deal with are
such that it doesn't fit into a nice
convex form here's the part I'm going to
gloss over using a bunch of magic from
my students they sort of figured out how
to convert this into both a sequential
quadratic programming problem and
actually a cone problem a second order
cone problem and then actually formulate
a certain sort of variables which then
allowed for linear constraints and then
what we could do is
this is the key Magic
as we say now our chance constraints
instead of looking for the mean
what we're doing is we're doing the
analysis of the possible contact or
conflict or Collision
with all distributions that actually
have the same mean and the same
covariance as the data we have at that
point so we're saying that's the best
approach you know approximation we have
but we know that it's a limited data set
so there may be other distributions you
know outside of that so we sort of make
this distributionally robust against
sort of all possible data
interpretations that we have
now this is a horrendous calculation and
so again a couple more Magics you can go
see in the paper and the extended
version is we find a way to reformulate
this and then actually convexify it so
we can actually do a real-time actually
a calculation of this so we can actually
do this 20 30 times per second in Matlab
so it's it's real real time
we haven't implemented it yet so we're
working on that but here's sort of a
simulation so the idea is this will play
over and over again is we've looked at
both footballs frisbees constant
velocity obstacles
um and so the idea is that actually
this is more risk averse and so you see
there's very large deviation Maneuvers
and here you're willing to tolerate more
risk and so you'll see on that side
there's
very little sort of deviation
okay
now the interesting thing and this is
why I'm really plugging this point
is we did uh 10 000 actually this not a
thousand ten thousand Monte Carlo
simulations of different risk levels and
different types of objects
and so what we found is applied along
here feasible means what percentage of
these 10 000 simulations could we
actually find a solution
and then next is of the feasible
Solutions what was the percentage of
avoiding the obstacle so 100 means we
avoided the obstacle all right demand is
how close did the obstacle get to Us
close as possible value during our
Patrol
so this is very risk-averse when you get
to risk equals one this is actually
stochastic planning so this is expected
value planning so what you see expected
value planning you always get a solution
but up to 40 percent of the time it
actually got hit by the obstacle when
you take risk into account almost uh 100
of the time it actually avoided the
obstacle and there's no penalty in costs
because we reformulate it in a way
that's very fast yes we lose the
percenter too in feasibility sometimes
so we're still working on that
okay I'm gonna wrap up now
um with the following idea you can
actually use a risk actually for
learning as well so this is very recent
work I can send you the paper we
submitted this to l4dc
so let's go back and think about our
drones again or other robotic vehicles
and we have a nominal model and then
there's some uncertainty but let's say
your nominal model is pretty good but
then all sudden you go out like you're
autonomously drone racing and a big win
kicks up that day you'd like to learn
that wind really quickly all right
um you know it may be transient so it
may not be around very long so you have
to have a very very fast learning
process
so prisfy akella a student of Aaron Ames
and then one of my students Skyler way
came up with the following idea
so we saw risk before so instead of
thinking about risk about a random
variable here we think what we introduce
what we call a surface at risk
so even though there's a fancy jargon
here the idea is very straightforward
so this transient disturbance here may
have a mean part it may have some
stochastic variation to it so I'd like
to learn it and so what I'm going to do
is I'm actually going to now bound
find actually an envelope
that's risk-based so I'm going to say if
you give me a certain level of risk I'll
find I can define an envelope of this
disturbance right here
so what we do then in real time is we
just use a gaussian process to quickly
learn this bounding envelope we then use
a robust control the openoff technique
which has disturbances built into it and
so the idea is if you can quickly learn
this disturbance by quickly identifying
which parts of the disturbance are going
to screw you the most then actually
learn those quickly and be able to
stabilize yourself quickly in the
presence of that disturbance and then
the disturbance goes away you can kind
of forget that term
so let's see this in practice
so here's again back in our drone Arena
so this is first the ground effect one
so here this drone doesn't know anything
about the ground effect and it's trying
to actually execute that path up there
and it's doing it but it's moving slow
because it has these buoyant forces that
it doesn't know about so it recognizes
like look there's something out of
distribution here that I don't
understand so let me take some time in
this case it only took 45 seconds so it
actually does a couple of motions it
learns about the Drone about the ground
effect and then after those motions it
can actually track quite precisely you
can actually then travel up to three
times the speed as before even with the
same accuracy
okay that's the ground effect what about
other kinds of things so in our drone
Arena
we have a kind of unique in the world uh
fan wall there's 1 600 individually
controllable fans here so we can
generate very complex wind flows
and so now this drone is trying to
follow this sort of spatial maneuver
here and it learned uh or its control
was designed without wind and now
there's two to four seconds of wind two
to four meters per second of wind in
this case
so you can't see the smoke but you can
see back here the curtains blowing so
there's the def you know evidence of the
wind and it's trying to follow this
trajectory but the wind kind of keeps
blowing it because it doesn't understand
um this wind so again with less than a
minute of data oh just driving through
that wind
um
it can then now very quickly and
accurately kind of track some trajectory
it's not perfect but it's getting there
but like I said it's very very little
data
okay I went fast because Mark told me I
had 10 minutes less than I had planned
and it's actually perfect because
um this is kind of my concluding almost
concluding slide so we have a new DARPA
program which is called learning and
introspective control where we're trying
to put all these ideas together
so in this program which is motivated by
the following problem people in the
military sometimes go out and Patrol and
overload their vehicles with stuff and
they roll over and die so they like to
have an onboard control system that
could automatically detect if the
vehicle is working out of spec then
actually decide if we need to redesign
the control system what data do we need
to learn and actually maintain safety at
all times during the learning and post
learning process
the way we're testing this is doing
absolutely crazy stuff this is just from
two weeks ago out in the actually
Arizona desert
we actually have to drive over these
very complex terrains
and then we have things like water tanks
on top where they vary the water and
sloshes around you can't tell but
there's a 20 mile with 40 mile an hour
gusts winds we have the sale on here so
it tilts it up so there's very little
traction sometimes so the traction slips
all the time and so here we're having to
do kind of you know sort of figure
eights not in this test but over the
next year they have to do things that
are going to drop out sensors
arbitrarily they're going to change the
control inputs arbitrarily for short
periods of time and introduce all kinds
of other artifacts and so the idea is
can you make a bad driver good and can
you take any driver when all hell breaks
loose and keep them safe and so we're
trying to put all these techniques to
use right now
so uh thank you for listening to me
speak very quickly and one of the
reasons I came here today I came here
today for two two reasons to see Mark
and Bernie and I'm looking for postdocs
um so if you're looking for a postdoc
let me know all right
[Applause]
yeah thank you for the talk it was
really exciting so I saw that in the
video all the drones were tethered so
each other is a safety tether is
required by our our flight testing okay
so now what Magnum do you use to make
sure that the Dynamics from the tether
is not affecting the flight yeah so we
spent a lot of time on that um so there
is an effect I can't tell you that
there's not but it's a disturbance so in
some ways we're just learning
disturbance the other thing we do is the
tether then has a counter balancing
system so we carefully wait for each
experiment to try to get to the minimum
tether sort of you know bias
too much about the Koopman style
modeling but I saw in your slides that
you enforce constraints in the MPC in
the lifted space especially when you're
learning that lifting how you ensure
that those constraints are actually
meaningful and getting used that's a
great question there's two ways to do it
actually the way we do it most of the
time is we take the lifted space and we
have a projection operator and we
project it back down so we actually
satisfy the constraint in the original
space so but it's by having then this
lifting unlifting operator
um and then another question I had is
when you were talking about your risk
averse uh planning you're planning
risk-averse with respect to some cost
functioning you notice that even if I
set my risk tolerance
is very fairly in the like it still
avoids collisions even if you're fairly
sense insensitive to risk
um that depends on what your risk
sensitive towards the cost function that
you're being misensive towards how did
you design that how do you get how do
you reason about that trade-off yeah so
the simulations I showed there we showed
very risk to moderate risk we didn't
necessarily show the gap for moderate to
no risk well so then you see a much more
of a transition sort of in that period
um you know we tried to make the theory
general for whatever cost function you
want but typically like I said we use
some of the classical cost functions
like cvar on the sort of actually chance
constraints so in this particular case
for the obstacle avoidance as
straightforward is what's the distance
between you and the nearest point in the
obstacle and so calculating your
estimate of C VAR on the Collision
constraint thank you
uh Great Tech thank you so much
um uh I was about the cook mine operator
part that you do lifting um I hope you
studied how this lifting can affect
real-time performance of MPC yeah it's
so one of the things that you do is is
I'm a practical engineer I want
everything to be real time so you see
everything there you know runs real time
and so what you trade off is the more
Dimensions you lift the more accurate
you're going to get the approximation
but the slower that you run so
oftentimes in practice the dimension we
lift to isn't yet uh dictated by a
rigorous Theory it's dictated by what
can we get to run in real time and so
we're trying to work on the rigorous
Theory we're not the only ones there's
lots of people right now I would point
you to some beautiful recent work by
Jorge Cortez at UC San Diego who's been
looking at how can you choose the
dimension of lifting so you can then
actually bound the error the you can
approximate what is the error in your
dynamical system as you know measuring
error in dynamic is a tricky thing and
so you have to you know there's issues
with that
hi a great talk I was wondering for the
wind gusts so in the arena if I
understand the wind is constant whereas
there's there's some variation in it but
I'll be frank with you like I said this
is only about a month old you know kind
of work uh and so we're working
currently on the variations
um I have a couple strategies we're
thinking about I'm happy to discuss
those but I'm not sure that's your
question
yeah I was wondering if you had thoughts
on learning Dynamics when the Dynamics
are time varying and how to design
things you and I chatted briefly at
lunch and so we're looking at can we
actually make a meta adaptive kind of
approach so that basically we can kind
of fold together different dynamical
systems adaptively in real time to deal
with the different gusts there's going
to be a lower limit right we're not
going to be able to correspond to every
small little transient in the winds and
there you basically use robustness you
know and have to just accept some
tolerance in your positioning and so if
you're doing things like obstacle
avoidance or other tasks like
manipulation you then have to build That
Into You know the planning technique
I was maybe wondering also for the risk
sensitive controllers do you think there
would have been other ways of make so is
a risk approach necessary to have robots
that account for uncertainty I can say
that on the other hand
um we were actually kind of surprised
how good our results were well I
actually wasn't expecting that
um the thing that I haven't had a chance
to do is would be able to extend it to
both non-linear systems and actually
non-gaussian noise
um so you know the technique's pretty
General and actually we've been able to
recently move it Beyond aerial systems
to ground systems and actually on the
ground it has an interesting effect it's
almost like an autonomous guided vehicle
so when the vehicles are going around
under this control or another vehicle
comes in front it basically stops in a
ways for it to go by and then sort of
continues on so it has many many nice
properties I'm sure you could come up
with a better Theory uh and this is the
one that we found and it's working for
us so we're sticking with it at the
moment
I have a question regarding the
equipment lifting so you mentioned
something about manipulation so is it
more so is it more effective for for
instance like the the wind it's more
soft compared to for instance if you had
like a lot of com contacts like in the
manipulation case for the equipment
lifting
I didn't quite hear the
song
yeah it's a good question I don't have
the answer for you we're actually
working on that right now what I can
tell you is there is there's only two
papers so the good news is when I
started doing Cooper Works you know six
years ago you could read the entire
literature in a week uh now you can't
keep up with the literature it's rapidly
expanding
the last time I checked there's only two
papers in the literature on hybrid
coupon systems so that's the idea is
that actually think about hybrid
dynamical system so there is a nascent
theory for dealing with hybrid equipment
system but it's really nascent
um you know and it's open area it's one
of the reasons I work in this and
there's still lots of open questions
and we probably need to to adjourn uh
thank you again for your time and yeah
[Applause]